Others who might not have been able to
get on the call. I also want to set up a
couple of group norms, because there's
going to be so many people on this call.
I mean, we are almost at 100 people
already and I want to make sure that we
can you know accommodate everybody as
much as we can. We'll try very hard to
make sure that we can answer questions
as they come. And, so I also want to say
that we are scientific researchers we
are not medical physicians, and so our
background are that of scientific
research, and we are not going to be
giving medical advice. This is explicitly
for the purposes of education. We are
probably, with the amount of people that
are here, I think it would be best if
everybody puts their questions into the
chatbox. So, anybody who doesn't know
zoom if you just sort of go to the
bottom, there's a little chat cloud
button. Feel free to pop them in there,
and we'll do our best to get those
answered. We are also zooming in from our homes.
My home is full of people and children, so
if you hear things like: dishes clamoring,
or my dog jumps on me, or my kids come
out asking me where breakfast is, I will
do my best to continue on, but I might
have to pause for a second to just run
our life. Because, we are also running our
life as we as we work. And, lastly we ask
that everybody recognize that we are all
here together, we want to respect one
another. Try not to talk over one another
if there is the opportunity to actually
ask questions through your video chat,
and yeah we just want to do our best to
make sure we can provide you with the
amount of information that could be
valuable for you. We're going to give you
some background about viruses, and then
pop into coronavirus specifically. But,
before we do that I think it's time for
us to introduce who we are. So, my name is
Jeanne Garbarino.
I am a Scientist and Director of RockEDU
Science Outreach at the
Rockefeller University in New York City.
This is a biomedical research facility
that does some of the top science
and biomedical research in the world. We
are lucky to have access to amazing
scientists and amazing information. And,
I'm joined by one of those scientists
today, and I'll introduce her in a second.
But, I am really excited RockEDU is a
program that we started in 2012 that
essentially connects biomedical research
communities with K through 12 for the
most part, but we're extending that now
because, Jeez, it's our prof-, it's
actually our profession to communicate
science. And, I will say that being on
these things have made me acutely aware
of chin hair, so I have plucked them for
you. All those who have beards, good, I'm
glad that you don't have to worry about
this stuff but you know pre-menopausal
women like myself yeah so no worries on
the sharing, but let's-- let's-- I'm gonna
kick it over to Gaby and allow Gaby to
introduce herself, and then we're gonna
jump right into our little virus
education session. all right well hey
everyone just to introduce myself my
name is Gabrielle kinesio I am currently
a first year graduate student at the
Rockefeller University but I've been
studying viruses for about four years
now great so um we're gonna give you a
little bit of a primer I'm gonna start
off by talking about viruses in general
because I think it's important that we
understand a little bit of context
before we start jumping into the cove
advice right um and so viruses are
actually very very small molecular
systems that require a host organism to
function so something else it requires
to be on something else to function
viruses are actually not considered to
be alive and that's because they can't
actually perform all of the metabolic
activities that a host cell would
normally do right and so to I want to
also demonstrate the size and scale of
viruses and we're gonna do that by first
looking at something for which we are
all familiar and I'm holding in my hand
and it's
hard to see but this is a coffee bean
everybody should be familiar with a
coffee bean right and I have to say I
took I was willing to take a single
coffee bean out of my my little stash
for you all but only one because I care
about you a lot but not enough to ditch
my stash of coffee but I want to share
with you my screen so I can kind of show
you the scale of the the viruses and so
we are gonna move over to this wonderful
resource that I really enjoy from the
learn genetics department of the
University of Utah and here you can see
a coffee bean and this is Times regular
12-point font that you might see in some
of the newspapers and we're just gonna
zoom in and show you where we are in
terms of size and scale we see the size
of a skin cell we see the size of a red
blood cell some X chromosomes we know
what bacteria everybody's probably heard
of bacteria here we are getting into the
bacteria sizes and now here we are at
the virus right viruses are actually
really really really small and so we
have an example of the measles virus and
the hepatitis virus the Rhino virus and
HIV and this other type of virus called
a phage okay so that's a little bit of
background on viruses and everybody has
or at least the size of viruses and
everybody knows what a pencil is right
and so if you look at a pencil and you
sharpen the pencil lid and you look at
the tip of the pencil viruses are so
small that a half a billion to a billion
individual virus particles can actually
fit I'm a very tip of your pencil I mean
that is just wild I can't even fathom
this this feels unimaginable to me
alright so the common feature of all
viruses is that they include a nucleic
acid genome a nucleic acid genome is
essentially the instructions for how to
build more virus particles
and this nucleic acid genome is
surrounded by an Armour of proteins some
viruses like the corona virus also
includes another surrounding layer which
is a membrane of fats and it is because
of this membrane of fat that scientists
and clinicians are urging people to
constantly wash their hands and that is
because if you think about what fats are
made of right so fats are these
molecules and they're very common in all
sorts of things that we do every day if
everybody's cook something like a
grilled cheese sandwich or some some
pork chops or something in a pan you
can't and there's all that grease layer
all over your pan you can't necessarily
take that that pin and just put it under
plain water to clean it right you have
to add soap and that is basically the
same physical principles of getting the
virus off of your Hands's you need that
soap is because of that Brown membrane
layer and so a virus exists to perform a
single overall function and that is to
transmit copies of their genomic
instructions into a host cell and they
want to get that host cell to make more
copies of the building blocks that
create that can create the virus and
then they want the host cell to help
them assemble those pieces to make new
virus particles and then release those
new virus particles into something that
they can continue to infect so they want
to go from one infected cell and then
make a bunch of stuff and to go into
more infected cells and as I had
mentioned they need to infect these
cells because they do not viruses do not
themselves possess the ability to
actually read their genetic instructions
and assemble more copies of themselves
so they hijack the machines inside of
host cells that normally do this and
they get rich off of the resources and
work of others all right so where did
viruses come from while it's really hard
to study how viruses emerged on the
planet especially since viruses are
really small and hard to detect and we
can't really look at like a fossil
record I mean while we can look at we
can consider their nucleic acids
as a kind of a fossil record but it's
not like we can physically look at rocks
and find like bones or anything because
viruses don't have those right and then
they also emerged a really long time ago
at a time when the earth looks extremely
different than it looks right now and so
there's some evidence that suggests that
viruses viruses could have emerged even
before the first cells on this planet
and then there's another theory that
suggests that viruses evolved along with
cells and represent escaped genes from
these cells and so genetically viruses
tend to look a lot like the cells that
they infect and this is a really
important important thing when we think
about like how viruses jump from species
to species and some of them have even
kidnapped host genes into their own
genomes to help them better infect cells
they're incredible molecular machines
but whichever camp folks are in there's
no denying that viruses are really
really old and because they've been
around for so long it's no surprise that
there are millions of different types of
viruses that infect all cell types and
we're talking plants and animals and
there's even viruses that infect
bacteria and the majority of viruses do
not actually impact humans there are a
ton of different viruses on us and in us
all of the time most of these actually
infect bacteria and in fact 40% of all
bacteria on earth are destroyed each day
by the special viruses that infect them
called phages of course they keep
growing the bacteria keep growing faster
than the phages can kill them which is
why that we still have bacteria and so
when we think about how many viruses are
around us one tiny drop of seawater
could contain like 10 million virus
particles and so as a whole viruses are
as like a whole thing are not really
that scary for humans however there are
some viruses that do impact animals and
n plants and animal and we are actually
an example of animals and so we are
currently in a situation where humans
are facing a brand-new strain of virus
on a really big scale and we're learning
new information about
every single day if not every single
hour and so here we're hoping to give
you some of the information that we
currently know about COBIT 19 and
provide an opportunity for you all to
ask questions and I'm gonna kick it over
to Gabby because she is really smart and
knows a lot more about coronaviruses
than I do so I'm gonna I'm gonna let her
take it from here
okay cool um so coronaviruses are
actually a really large family of
viruses and they're called corona
viruses because they're named for the
sort of spiky crown that surrounds the
virus and this crown actually serves a
purpose these are all of the receptors
that they used to bind to host cells and
essentially trick the host cell into
getting infected so inside of a corona
virus like a lot of other viruses it has
its genetic information stored in a
single strand of RNA and RNA is
basically like DNA it's only a little
bit different chemically um so
functionally in a Cell DNA has to be
translated into RNA before it can really
do anything um and so the virus by being
already RNA is sort of the minute it
gets in themselves
um you've also probably heard a lot of
names for this coronavirus um kovat 19
aras Co V - the novel coronavirus all of
these names
despite it sort of just making it sound
like you know damn of Thrones Khaleesi
level of his nonsense they all actually
do have a meaning and their naming it
for different facets of what it is so
because this one is new that's why we
called it the new one Co comes from
coronavirus VI from virus D for disease
in nineteen for the year um and like I
said there are a lot of different
species of corona virus um so this is
not necessarily like you know for the
most part we've seen these viruses
before the ones that cause the common
cold um so it's not like every corona
viruses you know the end of the world
because we only really hear about them I
feel like in the context of SARS
previously MERS previously and now this
so I'm actually going to
you should be able to screen share and
think great gee um walk you guys through
those really great New York Times
article the toxin goes through how the
corona virus gets into yourself um and
so I think it's good infographic for me
to walk everyone through see this is the
first time I've actually done this right
alright can everyone see that okay cool
so essentially this is the form of the
corona virus I'll scroll up a little bit
this is what it looks like from the
outside so these spikes those are what I
was talking about that gets at the name
the crown
and those are what fine two cells um and
then if this is a cross-section right
now that you're looking at so in the
inside is coiled that single strand of
RNA that's its genetic material it's got
the spikes sticking out through it and
then this layer that's in yellow is a
protein and lipid layer so as genes
saying the fats are actually really
important in the process of it getting
into cells and you'll see that in a
second um so the outer part of the spike
binds to a receptor that exists in our
airway cells so this is why it's a
respiratory virus and why it's not
blood-borne because these receptors it's
essentially the lock that it fits its
key into they don't really exist in
other parts of the body or at least not
in enough numbers for you to get much of
an infection rate um so once it reaches
a vulnerable cell the cell basically
eats it I don't know if it's shown
really well but you can see that this is
curving in here and it puts it in this
bubble um so once it gets into this
bubble the virus has the next problem
which then it has to escape from that
and that's where this membrane made up
fats comes in because the bubble that
the cell puts it in is also made of fats
so it sort of fuses with that to then
kick its RNA out into the cell um
and then once that's released then it
starts using the cells machines to take
it over and use and essentially make
more virus so it gets the viral RNA
translated is what we say it's
essentially when the song reads the
blueprint that the virus gave it starts
making virus proteins so the virus is
actually pretty small so essentially
once your cells have been converted to
little virus factories new viruses get
assembled and then pop out and that's
what makes you infectious essentially um
so I'm gonna stop screen sharing well
let's see everything should have gone
back to normal yeah we're back to
awesome cool hopefully that little
explanation made sense for everyone
about scientists can sort of assemble an
idea of where a virus came from um based
on something called codon optimisation
so in the genetic code different animal
species spell things kind of differently
they use different letters think of it a
little bit as like American versus
European spelling we spell color C olor
Europeans might Co L oh you are it
doesn't make a difference for how its
read it just makes a difference for how
it's spelled same thing for viruses and
for different animal species so what we
can do is because viruses have to match
the spelling of their hosts so they make
sense um we can look at that and sort of
compare it to what other animal species
it's similar to um and so because of
that we were able to sort of figure out
it's it's probably it probably came from
best um so I guess another question is
why did this spread so quickly um and
this was a really like all of the stars
online sort of situation a virus jumping
species is extremely random um it's just
random tiny genetic variations that
probably meant nothing to the bat
virus's ability to be a bat virus but
then all of a sudden when there was
exposed to people it let it infect
people if this had happened somewhere
with less people we might not be in this
situation right now so for example if
this had jumped from penguins in
Antarctica the olive I think 20 people
in Antarctica probably wouldn't have
been able to spread this to the entire
world it would have just gotten sick and
still been cold
but there's also other factors that I
think really played a role that's unique
to this virus so long incubation time
and asymptomatic people um so the long
incubation time essentially means that
it can take up to five days or longer
for symptoms to begin but you can be
infectious before then um so this means
that people could have gone about their
day and infected their friends family
and co-workers without even really
knowing that they were sick or that they
were shedding virus basically um and
having asymptomatic people essentially
contributes to this - so it seems like a
lot of people around my age between 20
and 30 um may not ever show symptoms of
having the virus which essentially means
that people went around their whole day
and accidentally got other people sick
without ever knowing that they
themselves had the virus so that's a big
part of why you know I'm currently
social distancing even though I'm not
sick
I'm hanging out just in my apartment so
that if I for some reason I am sick I
don't get other people sick so I think
maybe we can talk a little bit more
about why we're social distancing
because I mean it feels a little silly
to I think to just say let's shut down
life as we know it and all remain in our
homes right like especially if we're
seeing people like not a lot of people
are really showing symptoms like Gabby
just mentioned people in her age group
are not necessarily showing symptoms and
we know that kids for the most part are
not showing symptoms at all so if there
are so many people who are not showing
symptoms or experiencing a mild kind of
illness in response to the virus like
why why don't why would we social
distance in the first place and the
answers to that are actually pretty
interesting and complex and because the
virus is very new like humans overall
don't have our own immune system our own
innate immunity for that right now we've
never had to remember this in our immune
systems in the past we also know that it
is spreading very quickly and that's
mostly because we are a global society
we are on planes and train
and cars and we mix in large groups all
the time and because there are so many
potentials for asymptomatic transmission
I mean things can go really fast right
and as I had mentioned a lot of people
are not getting sick from this but and
those who are are for the most part are
actually mild but here's where the
social distancing is really important
right there are specific vulnerable
populations like populations who are
older populations of people who have
other types of illnesses and people who
have behaviors that could be associated
with health problems like smoking right
and so there are enough people in this
category for a specific town or city or
region that if all of the vulnerable
members of that community became sick at
once there would be no there wouldn't be
enough hospital beds and doctors to take
care of them and this essentially is
really really a big deal for our
healthcare systems it would mean our
health care systems become overloaded
and the normal level of care that we
would see you know on when when we were
able to hang out physically and not
personally we would see that this care
level would be significantly decreased
and if this happens people who get
copa90 may not be able to get the best
care that they need because doctors and
nurses and other hospital staff would be
stretched really thin and we've seen
this thing happen in other places where
they were not able to adequately control
the spread such as Italy and it also
means that not normal medical care or
even non Kovan 19 emergency care would
be significantly slowed and this is not
good
right so if anybody becomes hurt or you
know somebody has a heart attack or you
know some other kind of medical
emergency takes place I mean it would
impact our ability to respond to that -
right and so even though it feels a
little silly staying home means that
we're actually protecting both ourselves
and protecting each other
protecting the people that we love there
is I would say it's impossible that
somebody we don't somebody I mean I
think at this point I think somebody we
know probably has has the
virus at this point in time we just
don't know they might be in asymptomatic
so let's just minimize how much we're
interacting with each other it's also a
good reminder that we are a species
right and in order to survive sometimes
we really need to come together and
maybe this could be a lesson for us for
some of the other things that we need to
address as a society um like climate
change but we can talk about that
another time um and Gaby do you want to
talk a little bit about virus extinction
yeah I was gonna say I wanted to jump in
there really quick that um so there's
something really interesting about virus
extinction
so SARS is extinct the first stars um
and it's something that we don't have to
worry about getting again because we
made it so that it was not spreading
quietly throughout the population and I
think what part of the push is you know
to keep us all you know social
distancing and preventative training is
we don't want this to become the next
common flu I mean you hear the common
flu sighted all the time is being more
deadly that's just because it infects
more people so often um and we don't
really want to be fighting this virus
forever we don't want to have to get a
new you know coronavirus vaccine shot
every year although based on some
structural differences we may not have
to it really depends um the the flu is
particularly unique in the way that it
changes your deer um but we really want
to avoid that we don't want like I said
you don't have to be fighting this virus
forever so I think our goal right now is
to really quash it as fast as possible
um to make sure that this isn't a
recurring health problem yeah so should
we get into where we are with the cure
Gaby do you want to talk about that a
little bit yeah I can definitely talk
about that um
so there's pretty good news is there a
cure your own immune system No so most
people only have mild symptoms and
recover completely you're really really
good at fighting these things off and um
after we're
after you fight something like this off
your body's pretty good at remembering
that it's hot in the first place and
fighting it off again um we are also a
scientist working a lot on ways to stop
this so there's two different arms that
scientists go about preventing or it's
treatment and prevention those are the
ways that we approach viruses um so
treatment we tackle those through
antivirals for the most part um so
antivirals aren't antibiotics per se
they're things that really slow the
progression of the virus um so I think
right now the - um but I think people
are like specifically for this for so um
are things called nucleoside analogues
where essentially they're like messed up
letters of the genetic code and the
virus can't really spell together can't
really tell that those are different and
so it winds up incorporating those in
its instructions for the next virus and
so the next virus when it gets those
messed up instructions can't execute its
functions properly because all of the
instructions are scrambled spelled
backwards stuff like that um and so
that's essentially the purpose of a
nucleoside analog I think there's two
that are currently being tested right
now predominantly in places with higher
density infections like China um so
they're a little ahead of the curve on
developing that um there's also um for
the prevention angle which is vaccines
vaccines take generally a lot longer
than antivirals because it's hard to
make sure that you're going to have
protection forever basically um so for
example think about the shots that you
probably only got once or twice as a
child and you have immunity now it's
kind of hard to make a vaccine that
perfect um so that requires a lot of
refinement but at the same time what
we're not looking for is perfect right
now the vaccines that we're probably
going to be looking for are things that
have some small reduction um so
essentially something that we can get
healthcare workers to reduce the
likelihood that they'll get sick and so
a lot of these things right now are
really gonna go into treating the people
who have bad cases where the antivirals
would probably decrease how bad like
their decreased their symptoms and
reduce how bad their symptom Lotus and
also preventing healthcare workers from
getting it and help them stay on their
feet for long enough to keep you know
the people who are the most sick Cathy
so I think we'll start pulling the
questions from the chat box and we have
a question from Laura that asks about
how long the viruses live on surfaces
and this is a really good question and
there has been a lot of work on this in
the last couple of days and there was a
recent paper that was published just the
other day that that says hold on let me
find all of my data so I don't so I
don't misspeak oh the stability of the
virus is definitely dependent on the
surface and for example plastic in
stainless steel has showed the presence
of viable virus at 72 hours after being
exposed whereas a material like copper
or cardboard only she doesn't show
viable virus by 24 hours and I think
this is like the whole material thing is
a really big thing that we have to
consider and this is why people are
suggesting that you you know what if you
live in a building you're wiping down
your elevator buttons on the regular
basis you're wiping down your doorknobs
and it's probably why a lot of places
are deciding to close their playgrounds
even though we want to get out and want
our kids to burn off some energy a
playground is mostly made of plastic
right and if kit if we can consider kids
as little vectors that are you know it's
not really dangerous to them but they
can spread it to all these other people
it's really important that we're taking
these measures to make sure that we can
maintain safety for everybody and so in
terms of how long it's it can transmit
from a specific surface it depends on
the surface and more data is probably
going to come out on that with more
specific guidelines in the coming days
or weeks I would say okay what other
questions let's see what we can answer
all right hold on sorry there's a lot of
we don't have a lot of cushion because
I'm trying to go in the chat
yeah if you don't think we can get to
them so I'm trying to think so I want to
answer one that I saw okay
yeah the virus is not a retrovirus you
do not have to worry about having this
forever it is a transient infection um
so that just means that like a cold or a
flu once it's done it's done
you are not infected with it but part of
the reason why were still worried about
corona virus is because it seems like
people might shed virus essentially are
no longer sick but still are in the
process of clearing that virus and may
still be infectious to others so it's
probably safe to treat even if say
you've been in quarantine for 14 days
you've been sort of on lockdown in your
house and you think that you're better
now to stay inside for an extra couple
of days to make sure that you're not you
know that you're you're fine and I don't
know if we're doing secondary testing
for people who think they've recovered
yep because I know I think very small
data sets coming out of places in China
and South Korea but you know they did
just come out with a paper this morning
or last night actually on bio archive
which is a repository for people to put
their reports in before they become peer
reviewed so it's a really really amazing
resource for scientists because it
allows for information to be pushed out
really quickly um but they did and I'm
not sure if you just mentioned just that
they did show that in monkeys monkeys
who had been infected with with Kovac 19
they are not they're not getting recent
they're not getting reinfected which
suggests that maybe our immune systems
you know it's sort of like a
one-and-done once we get infected it's
it's quite possible that we're not gonna
get reinfected and so I think that's a
really positive finding for for people
um there is a question oh yeah go ahead
go ahead
well no I so I always see something
about
people asking a bunch of questions about
when something mutates and I yeah I
always want to tackle this because it's
a really interesting thing from a
science perspective that a lot of people
who aren't scientists aren't exposed to
so mutation sounds scary everyone thinks
of you know what like contagion or
something like that like some crazy
sci-fi and dramatists strain kind of
thing it's not what it means for
scientists
so viruses mutate all the time all of us
mutate all the time but it's not usually
good so for us we're mutating constantly
that's how eventually some of us get
cancer but our bodies are pretty good at
cleaning it up the virus mutates to as
the goes from you know inside your body
and from person to person but usually
this is way more likely to produce
non-functional virus or virus that's
worse at being a virus than some magic
super bug and I want to explain a sort
of concept in virology that I think is
kind of important to refocus how we
think about viruses a viruses goal is
not to get you sick its goal is to
spread if making you sick helps with
that so for example making you cough on
to other people so you spread it the
virus will probably always have coughing
symptoms but for the most part the
viruses that I think are the best
viruses and being viruses are the ones
that don't make you sick thanks for sick
that sick think about the common cold
everyone gives each other the common
cold and we don't really care about it
that much same thing about there's a
virus that I think 98% of us have or at
least have been in contact with
it's called epstein-barr and none of us
get sick or a small fraction causes mono
but that's like a very small fraction
considering how many people are exposed
to it so the concept of the virus
mutating doesn't mean that we're going
to get a super super mega virus what it
means instead is something a little bit
closer to why we have to get a flu shot
every year
so we're going to probably there's sort
of host and virus tug-of-war that
happens and we talked about virus host
interaction as scientists and evolution
as scientists and so if anything the or
worried the most about the outside of
the virus changing a little bit over
time and the same way that the outside
of the flu change isn't overtime we're
essentially we're going to need a
different or multiple vaccines and
that's giving it the least amount of
opportunity to change is part of why
we're trying to take all these measures
now um so that like I said we don't have
to get a shot for this every year or we
don't have to develop you know multiple
stage vaccines because it looks a little
bit different on the outside and the
look of that virus is essentially how
our bodies recognize it to begin with
great um let's see uh let's see what we
have four more questions we have
somebody on here Luke who is also
answering some questions for us so thank
you so check out Luke's answers in the
chat it's gonna say Luke just popping
the chat like I'm just curious like what
do you do yeah do you are you from
rockefeller like it's kinda like I mean
we have other scientists who are in the
chat using this app yeah yeah okay so we
saw that corona virus is not a
retrovirus there were some other
questions that maybe we can talk about
including maybe how we test for SARS
coab - virus right and so as Gaby
mentioned the SARS code - virus has a
set of instructions inside of it for
building more copies of itself and this
particular virus uses RNA to write these
instructions and RNA is a type of
nucleic acid and it has a lot of
similarities to another molecule that
we're very familiar with I think most of
us are probably familiar with DNA so our
bodies have both DNA and RNA but in this
case for the virus the RNA is the main
source of genetic instructions and just
like DNA RNA has four letters and it is
the C
once of these letters that sort of form
the recipe for building the virus and in
order to test for Koba 19 scientists and
clinicians have to extract RNA from a
sample and usually this sample is you
know you put it like one of those nasal
like q-tips those really long q-tips up
your nose and then you use all the I'm
just going to use a very scientific term
you'll use all that goop to to get the
RNA out of that nasal swab and then you
make a ton of copies of that RNA so that
there's enough of those letters that we
can read it and then we look at the
sequence of those letters to see if
those letters match to the kovat virus
or the SARS co2 virus and so that's how
the virus is tested and it takes a
little while for that to happen it's
quite a process because you have to do
the RNA extraction which is a several
hour thing and then you have to make a
bunch of copies let's takes a couple of
hours and then you have to sort of read
though that the letters in those copies
and that takes a couple of hours and so
it's a long process it's not like when
we go to the doctor and we take one of
those rapid flu tests where we know like
very fairly soon so right now it's a
very slow process and it is a bottleneck
for community testing and I think we're
now ramping up our capacity to do this
on a larger scale but until now it was
very specific in terms of who was
eligible to get that test I also really
quick want to mention something because
it ties in with testing um so a bunch of
people in the chat are saying that it's
spreading lightning fast it's not really
spread that's happening right now you're
watching cases go up dramatically in the
last couple days especially in New York
this is not because in one day it
infected you know a thousand more people
it just means that we tested way more
people so in reality part of the reason
why everything's shutting down is
because we expect that our estimation
based on confirmed cases is much lower
than the amount of people who actually
have come in contact with the virus so
it doesn't mean that like whoo you may
already be infected like I don't want it
like scare you guys like that um
it's sometimes scarier when you think
that it's spreading lightning fast that
like in a day we're all gonna be
diagnosed positive for coronavirus in
reality we just really lagged on testing
and so we're trying to catch up with
that now it's essentially like was it
was a China or South Korea that started
when they bumped up their testing that a
huge spike and South Korea I think it
was a Korea massive community testing
like everybody what happened was is if
you look at their statistics there's
this huge chunk that makes it seem like
in a day everyone got it but that's not
accurate it just meant that over the
last you know three days that many more
people had got it and they suddenly were
now able to test for it so it's gonna
seem scary over the next you know week
as the US really ramps up this testing
infrastructure because it's gonna seem
like cases are popping up out of
everywhere but in reality they were
already there
yeah which he's also wearing but that's
why we're social distancing now before
you know we reach some threshold number
of cases yeah and and again just to
emphasize while more people probably
have the virus than we can detect at the
moment again it's very on it's the
majority of people will either be
asymptomatic or have mild symptoms it's
really the vulnerable populations that
we are concerned about and the the
overwhelming of our health care systems
and so I think for the most part people
should be vigilant you know they should
practice the the important things that
we can do to protect each other like
staying inside having six feet of space
between us if we do end up going out
washing our hands trying to avoid
touching our faces and like wiping down
things like you know doorknobs and
phones and keyboards and things that
other people can can touch and so you
know it feels a little scary to be in
these situations but I think overall you
know there are people out there worrying
about this for you and you know just do
your part and you know snuggle with your
pets a little bit more maybe watch it
maybe up you're watching of Netflix or
Hulu um like you know so I think you
know we can we can sort of
some of the anxieties that we might have
because people are on this and I also
want to emphasize the wonderful
wonderful resource that the scientists
and clinicians in Asia have been
providing the world the work coming out
of China the work coming out of South
Korea I mean we cannot be more grateful
for the wonderful information and the
resource sharing that they are providing
to our communities and so I really want
to emphasize the value of the work that
these scientists have gone through and
you know being on the front lines I mean
they they were the ones who helped warn
the world that this was coming their way
and we really should be grateful for to
these scientists and physicians for
their service I'm seeing some great
questions that I want to answer so two
things it seems to be about prevention
and also testing one that's you told the
testing kits are limited what exactly
are we lacking in so there seems to be a
couple of things um
then each testing kit might be a little
bit different by the way um just based
on what bait they use to fish out the
genes of the virus um we call those
probes and what it seems like we're
limited in right now or at least what I
was reading earlier is the kits that we
use to extract the genetic information
from the virus so RNA is notoriously
less stable than DNA um it degrades kind
of fast and you want to make sure it
doesn't degrade so that you can read it
properly
um and so that is you you need really
really clean materials because there's a
lot of stuff all over everything that we
touch that degrades RNA it's just sort
of in the environment um and so we need
stuff that will stabilize it and will
prevent it from being degraded um and
that has to be made really carefully a
lot of us scientists can't make that in
our own lands because we don't have you
know a ton of chemicals and the space
for it so we rely on a lot of the places
that make these kits these RNA
stabilization kits that's essentially
like use buffer one use buffer to use
buffer three it's very like
straightforward and that's what's
limited it's not necessarily that
there's a limited amount of scientists
because the process is actually very
easy even me as a first-year graduate
student I could have done this as an
undergrad um but we are actually limited
in clinical lab space people who are
certified to work with patient samples
like I'm only certified to work with
like stem cells um nothing that's coming
really really directly out of a person
um
and then someone else asked about masks
so part of the thing about masks is that
it's they're gonna be in short supply
for healthcare workers especially it's a
lot more important for them to wear
masks to be able to have some sort of
barrier in case you know the people who
are sick who they're working with sneeze
on them um for us just going to get our
groceries you don't need a mask and you
don't need to be hoarding masks to take
them away from people who need them um
masks also to speak a little
discouragingly
for you guys the masks that we use in a
bsl-3 facility where we work with
dangerous viruses yep those are the n95
masks people who've been standing them
up so fast that one researchers like
myself who need them can't get them and
to these masks you have to be fitted for
and they have to be really really
specific um and so I've seen people out
on the street you're wearing an 95s with
big gaping holes in the side of them
that do nothing to help you so using
masks for trained health care workers
that you yourself don't know how to use
is not going to help you similar thing
with surgical masks they're not like the
end-all-be-all you're now in a bubble
just because you have a mask on your
face and in fact a lot of people wear
them for so long that they get wet and
it's stuff can still come out
essentially so wear one if you're sick
because it is a good barrier um
you know if you're coughing then it's
not that's not going to fly through that
as much um but if you're just a regular
person
don't be hoarding these masks because
the people who are really needing them
yeah and if I can add just one thing on
the RNA kits there is a company called
kaya Jen that is
Brassica Lee upping the production of
these kids so that they can be district
distributed to scientists and clinicians
who are doing COBIT testing and then
secondly regarding the n95 mask
I think Gabby makes an excellent point
in that um you know being fitted for
this is essential and one of the
processes just to explain what that
looks like somebody who would be fitted
for an n95 mask what they would do is
they would put on the mask and they
would go into a small chamber and then
there would be some aspartame which is
you know people have tasted like an
artificial sweetener aspartame would be
aerosolized and if you can taste it then
you have to get back out and then get
the mask refitted and it's a series of
getting your mask fitted and then spring
aspartame to see if you can taste it and
then going back out several times it
takes health care workers sometimes
several times to get this right so to
consider that we just regular people
could just go pop um and an n95 mask and
be protected is actually not real thing
and so please everybody do not purchase
n95 masks just for your home use you are
taking valuable resources away from
health care workers and this is a really
important product that we need to make
sure that they are safe so that they so
that we end up still having doctors and
nurses who can help us I think also I
was gonna say I'm seeing other questions
about ibuprofen because this is a thing
that happened recently so the CDC I
think the WHI put out a thing about you
should probably avoid ibuprofen if you
have coronavirus so this seems to be an
interesting thing I've been looking into
it um I don't think you know it means
that you know you're gonna die if you
took an ibuprofen and you're sick what
it seems like is happening is so there's
some older data from a while ago I don't
think it worked with I don't think it
use coronavirus think it used I think
was about the flu um that it didn't seem
Elmo as much those are different viruses
um so I think currently it's based on a
lot of anecdotal things from nurses and
doctors that they're seeing people who
are taking ibuprofen might be coming in
with were symptoms because there's no
statistics yet
I am a little leery of how pronounced
this thing is essentially it's a little
bit of a thing about how if someone
tells you to look for something you
start seeing it everywhere you learn a
new word sold sudden you start hearing
it um I don't know how much of this is
enough people finally like a nurse asked
like the first 10 patients who walked
through the door with it did you take
ibuprofen they all took ibuprofen and
maybe two of them had more advanced
symptoms so then that nurse thought okay
now it's ibuprofen that's doing this I
don't know if it's correlation as
opposed to causation is something that
you'll hear a lot of scientists say but
I would keep looking stuff up as this
continued I would trust the WHL which
essentially means you know if you have
ibuprofen use it for a headache um if
you start coming down with Coral virus
and you have Tylenol use that instead um
that's basically my standpoint on this
so there's a question there's a couple
of questions around the anticipation of
how long we need to maintain social
distancing and so I want to try to
address that and I just want to say it's
very hard to predict exactly how much
time we're gonna need to do this right
it's clear that we have to protect each
other and it's clear that business as
usual or at least sort of how we thought
about normal life definitely needs to
shift we have to continue to assess how
well our measures for social social
distancing are working or maybe not
working we have to assess where we are
on treatments including how efficiently
we can distribute these treatments to
those who are facing any kind of kovat
19 issues and we also have to consider
how long it will take us to get an
effective vaccine and not to mention
also developing our own innate immune
systems to be responsive to any of this
virus um there's some good news in a
recent report that suggests that
reinfection is unlikely meaning that
there is evidence to suggest that once
you get this particular strain you
become immune to it as we sort of talked
about before but we do need more data on
this to be entirely sure and at least
the work is promising and I want to
while we're facing these answer
times it's actually not entirely clear
some scientists are saying that we have
to maintain social distancing for
actually a really long time maybe
something like a year but I don't I
don't actually know if that's something
that we can say with any kind of
confidence without some of the more
information that we're getting regarding
these other things that I just discussed
um but there is a quote from dr. Fuji
who is basically leading the efforts in
our government I think that they are
very very respected and I think they
have really he has a really good take on
things in the quote that he says is and
the thing I want to emphasize is when
you're dealing with an emerging
infectious disease outbreak you were
always behind where you think you are if
you think that today reflects where you
really are right and so it's really just
getting a handle of what's happening
we're still getting data we're still
processing the data trying to understand
what the data mean and I think what we
all have to do is just be patient and
listen to trusted sources and think
about how we how we can just work our
lives into this new reality of social
distancing for now I mean I don't know
whoever bought stock in zoom you are now
rich
I also noticed so this is I saw someone
post a question a while ago for it got
drowned out by chat nonsense about a
quinine and chloroquine I never know if
I'm pronouncing that right um that's
been an interesting thing that's come
out of this someone asked about the
chemistry of it um my my pee I actually
sent us pee I in my lab he actually sent
us a whole big thing about those stuff
that's been coming out about this
according to what they were saying
hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine they
are used predominantly against malaria
which is a little bit wild that someone
thought to use this in the first place
it seems like it raises the pH which is
essentially um as PHS acid
hi pH is bass and of that little bubble
that the virus get sucked into when it
get put in cell the virus relies on
being acidic that's how it knows it's
inside a cell and that's how it starts
pulling itself close to that bubble so
that it can dump its its RNA out into
the cell and so what this does is it
seems like it might slow the stages of
early infection and help like contain it
within a person a little bit by making
that bubble a little bit less you know
cushy for the virus I'm not giving it as
easy of a time to push its RNA out into
the cell so it's it's pretty interesting
I think there are clinical trials in
China Oh South Korea Japan France in the
u.s. um so I feel like we will probably
see this um used for healthcare workers
or those at high risk of infection
um so someone was talking about in the
chat um cystic fibrosis
that would probably be a person that
would be able to get this if it starts
rolling out these are early tests though
um I don't think they've been done on a
lot of people I think they're these I'm
trying to look for the face because that
tells me how far they've gone I can't
find it right now and this email um but
if that starts rolling out and that
seems promising through continued trials
that might be something that we start
you know seeing distributed in hospitals
and to those who are the most at risk
great so there's a ton I feel like I
have something that says 99 plus new
questions so we're trying to go go
through these a little bit so that we
can make sure that we are doing our best
so let's see I think there are some
questions around people with immune
suppression and I think I it is these
are people who do have immune autoimmune
diseases or immune suppression
and any kind of taking medications to
suppress their immune systems this is
these are this is the these are the
people that I think really need to work
on really being very vigilant about
social distancing and ask the people
around you if you're in a home with
anybody to also make sure that they are
vigilant about social distancing so I
think that's that's really important um
let's see what other questions do we
have going on let's I'm answering the
ones about flu tests right now I would
suggest scrolling up a little bit I'm
sorry I'm trying to like I said I'm
trying to get through as many on the
chat as I can yeah
you might just have to make like an
ongoing yeah and also where we are
approaching a one hour time point so
maybe we can try to answer one or two
more questions but I think you know we
should probably take this and we'll try
to post this on YouTube and we'll also
try to you know provide more instruction
so Rakhi to you is actually generating a
whole resource around viruses and you
can look for that at Rock edu dot
rockefeller edu we have a bunch of
teaching resources that we could use and
we also have a blog and so we'll try to
get all of this stuff on on our blog and
you can also follow us on Instagram
we'll probably doing a bunch of
Instagram stories around this as well
and I am going to type in our Instagram
handle so that you can see that and I
think some people on my team so yeah dis
san is on my team
Lizzie Oh jealous if Lizzie if you can
post we have an exit survey so if you
can tell us about how this went for you
so that we can continue to do these
things and so look at the chat box and
please fill out our survey so that we
can hear from you how did this go did we
hit the right levels is there something
that we should do to make your questions
a little bit more reasonable or I don't
know like where are we how are we doing
let us know how that
how that's going cool uh I think maybe
do we have one you want what do we want
to hit one more question and then maybe
we'll call it a day for now oh let's see
the new ones so I think there was a
quick thing about the flu tests is are
quick and easy
and they're just a different type of
test right and so they they're they're
based on a different type of measurement
and you could do that really quickly in
a doctor's office maybe we'll get there
with Co good we just don't know what
kind of markers to look for right now to
to you know other than the straight-up
DNA or I'm sorry straight-up RNA excuse
me it is RNA um yes you're working
though very fast there's been a lot of
um I think I really think I read
somewhere like Ireland it like some
scientists there develop like a faster
test like a lot of this stuff so someone
says they make a faster test we
obviously have to verify that scientists
like data so what they try to do then is
they try to roll out and see how it
works
and they have to compare it against the
tests we already have they can't just
roll out a new test and not have
anything to compare it to because then
how do we know that it's not diagnosing
people right fortunately at least for
the tests that we have even if it takes
a while the rate of a false negative as
in saying that someone doesn't have
current a virus when they do is really
low so if you get a coronavirus
diagnosis so you or someone you know
does you can have pretty good confidence
in the science that says that you have
corona virus don't think either wrong no
no no it means you should definitely
take that job yeah cool all right I
think we are probably gonna call it a
day look for this on youtube if you had
people who were not able to join but you
think this could be a value we'll get
this out I don't want to make any huge
promises but maybe we can have it by
tomorrow
don't hate me Lizzie with this process
but we're really trying to figure out
like how we can be like again we are
part of a science outreach team
and it is our profession to connect
people to research information and we
usually do this in person and so we're
really trying to figure out how can we
do this in an effective way when we're
not allowed to be in person anymore and
so yeah continue being in touch I'm
gonna throw my I'm gonna be a risk taker
and throw my email in the chat box I
people are like don't do it don't do it
but I want to make myself available so
you have ideas we are also hoping to
connect with both New York City teachers
and New York City students through some
other initiatives where we can maybe
pair people with scientists to try to
figure out ways for helping people with
their education in those ways and I am
glad that everybody is giving us some
pretty useful feedback don't forget to
answer our survey that the link is in
the chat and here is my email address I
I get bombarded I will try my best to
get back to you okay well thank you
again be healthy be well wash your hands
stop picking your nose stop rubbing your
eyes I I mean and you know when we're
all on here I'll continue to Chuck all
of my chin hairs so they're not only but
whatever if we do okay um all right
peace out everybody enjoy